in the future entertainment will be  randomly generated randomly generated  randomly generated what better way to  achieve the unexpected I've seen the  future Bob and the future is famous hey  those are robots so firm ative not only  that but these guys represent the hosts  of the future unlike us their humor can  be truly randomly generated red guys why  did the chicken cross the road now  that's funny that doesn't make any sense  it's funny because it's unexpected well  whatever happened to it's funny because  it's true two plus two equals four is  true but not funny guys what is the  solution to the equation 2 plus 2 2 plus  2 equal weedeater